how's it going bros my name is peter pat
today we're looking at
crappy design can i say that can i say
the c word oh god
i actually feel very passionate about
crappy design because it pisses me off
more than anything in the world i don't
know what it is especially things that
are normal
and we've all just accepted even though
it's like toilet seats always breaking
what's up with that sinks don't even get
me started on sinks
and don't even get me started on
ceilings
spit on you oh they spit back
one day all right let's get into the
video
i'm actually hyped alright so we have
the the wheels on the new mac pro don't
have locks
they cost 550.
[Music]
i love this because it's apple you know
you open their products
made in california that's what it says
it's made they wouldn't put manufactured
in china but
designed design it's sorry the design is
what it says
designed in california guys well done
californians
here's a round of applause for your
californians you're dead edge
you've actually blown us away with your
design skills that looks
[ __ ] it looks so flipping ugly and you
should all be ashamed of yourself
first of all logo is way too big there's
no styling that
second of all whoever decided this was a
good idea
shoot him that's right i'm not saying we
need to kill people
i'm just saying we need to shoot them if
they do crappy designs
then no more crappy designs no more
sinks all right what do we got here the
absolute crap design of my school this
is the place where every hallway
intersects
you know i really wanted to study
architecture uh my granddad study
was an architect and uh i feel like it
it would have suited me well
i always think there's so many people
that shouldn't be architects and here
you go here's a perfect example
of why if you can't get this right
in morons sorry i'm telling you this
this stuff i don't know what it is
it really really annoys me so much you
know okay
puppet meme who controls the world it's
those goddamn crappy designs
making it worse for everyone because
once it's done no one changes on it
all right ladies and gentlemen the
pinnacle of human stupidity
uh they do this in japan actually i was
kind of confused by it and i
i don't get it either i feel like this
one has a reason behind it let me see
take the peel off the banana entirely
put the plastic wrap around it
then put their original peel back on
over the wrapping
genius oh here we go they do this in
japan for all their fruit and most of
the veggies
it's a goddamn nightmare all right so
there's no good reason
wouldn't it technically make it last
longer am i wrong
for saying that it's that dumb i don't
know
i've seen this oh the plastic
damn you plastic all right let's let's
put this
out
this is such a perfect example of the
people that i like to
but i want to say boasting about guys we
need to do something about all the
plastic
oh god that's how i broke my leg
i don't know i'm laughing someone broke
their leg that's awful but
this sign should we make it stared
all the way no no no no no no no
that's innovation at its finest well
done
the designer of this you did it you made
the world a worse place congratulations
crappy designers you did it
you did it see they are these people are
the worst shoot them
if you're watching i'm gonna shoot you
there's nothing it's not illegal
never buy cheap carpets for your car
okay what happens if you buy cheap
carpets for your car
the thing will slide over your uh gas
pedal right
yeah oh my god
uh i don't know
i don't know what to say lauren keeps
the look neutral by stacking books
back to front i see so many people do
this
all the time what's wrong i get that it
looks better but my god
so obnoxious to be fair most people have
books in their houses
just to show up as decor anyway so
really
what's the difference at least in this
way yeah this is the
less pretentious way what the hell it's
confusing
uh what should the men in blue
do
[Laughter]
ah jeez that's a tough one what should
he do
what should he do i get the question
it's like it's more of if you're morally
complicit of of the action of doing
something
is that is that making you involved of
uh killing even though it's less
a car opens and it lets all the water in
the trunk
you literally could just wipe it off
though bro come on i know that
that's bad design but i don't know man
am i so selective some
some of them make me so angry other ones
yeah
you'd have to be [ __ ] to get that wrong
anyway i don't really care
that's just funny i want i want come on
i want more specific product ones
advertising plus size legging with a
small model in one leg instead of
getting
plus size model that's just big brain
right there
they probably just want to save money
using the same model for
a bunch of products uh i can't really be
mad at that either
hey bro you want some chips without
chips come on bro have some
it's delicious only 199
i'll have the chips without chips please
i don't know i'm not mad at this either
because it would just make the whole
thing annoying you'd have to put this
here right
again you'd have to be [ __ ] to get that
wrong or confused
every single front door in my uni halls
all right you can reach that can you
if you want to see crappy designs just
watch lock picking lawyer
just absolutely destroying locks
embarrassing
to be honest i was expecting a bit more
from a company
i don't know what's so funny about it do
die dude i do
why would they make that green it's
either do die or don't drive safely
don't drive safely bros all right thank
you flyer i remember
apple says clean apple cart with a
microfiber cloth avoid
contact with leather and denim
looks at wallet looks at pens oh no
no no joke's on you apple i keep my
cards between my junks
my junks yes i have many
hey bro wouldn't it be epic if we put
the toilet and the sink
i get what they're trying to do use the
same same plumbing right
and hide it all neatly oh that's so good
at least that the toothbrush get got to
go on a fun ride at least she got
oh god i love these so good shoot them
it will solve the problem
apple on the forefront of crappy designs
they can keep getting away with it just
don't stop buying apple products it's
not that hard
valencia i guess new five thousand
dollar dress i
i like it if you knew what most
dresses cost at like uh red carpet
events you wouldn't be complaining about
this one
who the flip thought glass bathroom
stalls would be a good
idea see another perfect example because
that costs a lot of money to set up but
no one's going to bother to change it
although you could just put a film over
it couldn't you
still man who are these people
why are they so many of them and how are
they so dumb
from this beauty at my local college
this is me trying to fit stuff perfectly
in animal crossing it's the exact same
thing
no everything i'm possible what
what in the world are you trying to say
know everything i'm
um is possible what
nothing is possible
everything nothing um is possible
i'm possible is simple
no every
world war eleven that's a good one that
was a fine one
time travelers be like yeah i remember
oh my god yes
this is such a perfect example it's such
a minor
thing that you're overlooking but it has
annoying consequences and that i think
that's what
designed to to me or crappy design and
this is really what stands out
this is your job do it right please oh
god
i don't know i don't know man uh sitting
at a
chair cringe cringe
oh my oh oh my
oh no
i'm curious if you guys have any uh
graphic design
suggestion or uh i feel like everyone
has one in their mind
something that's bothering you i want to
hear it in the comments
for me it's definitely sinks and taps
especially how in uk and i said this
before how it's either blistering hot
or ice cold why it's 20 20
fix it fix it don't even get me started
on the pressure and the fact that i have
to wait 30 seconds for it to even get
hot
and then five seconds for it to from go
to hot to blizzarding hot
so then i have to adjust it while i do
it i hate it i hate it so much
i hate it this is how we solve the
epidemic we make it so it's actually
nice experience for people to wash their
hands
oh oh wow this is this
uh cheap built i don't know any sort of
elevator or
pushing mechanism should have a simple
infrared sensor to know
if something is on top of it for safety
reason it doesn't cost much
that's just really dumb please enter
your pin
[Laughter]
oh god i can relate to this
you can tell people just walk straight
on it too that's hilarious
bro bro let's do this someone made this
you have to understand someone this is
first someone designed this
then so someone paid to cut up these and
then they had someone to lay it down
and nowhere in the process said someone
[Music]
i don't even want to put my finger in is
that what the expression is ew
i don't want to dip my toes that's it
but maybe we shouldn't do that just
maybe
hell yeah oh look at their skin
damn they look good i want that product
damn can i look that good
damn they paid to advertise on this as
well
just another little note there someone
spent money for this tv show
oh god all right what have we got i have
to check under the
agitator after every load
oh my god that's just annoying
my pants handle is too heavy for it to
stay flush
with the stovetop oh my god it's almost
kitchenware isn't it
it's always kitchen related stuff this
is another perfect example
someone designed this someone did this
and it's the thing you don't know
until you bought it either that's the
problem isn't it no
no no no
thank you book thank you that's so
nice what you're saving the world thank
you
oh i got hiccups now oh no yeah design
flaw in human body huh
why i gotta do it do this huh
[Laughter]
damn
i never i've never been to india but man
people that died people beat small god
damn that's like not even
that's like four times the height in
latvia you must be giant there
what is happening what is that what oh
god i'm losing it
oh no
[Laughter]
oh man american bathroom has no privacy
it's so shocking every time i go i'm
like
looking through the cracks what are
people doing i don't like it
i'm not looking through no no
safety warning it's made in chile guys
please be cautious this is made in chile
oh god
it seems clear to me that in school they
need to do a better job at teaching
people how to make graphs
because it seems like this is half the
subreddit jesus christ
uh well done
[Laughter]
oh god what side you want soap
on your crotch absolutely coming right
up
[Laughter]
oh god that's so annoying i hate it i
hate it
i hate it what is happening
what is happening
oh it's the oh because why pave the
actual
pathway oh my god why would you do that
this is just so confusing i don't
understand what goes through people's
brains
nice now that looks nice
well done we gotta built in
washing machine oh yeah
that looks good new lockers
are you serious
lock picking lawyer be like bro keyboard
for a few bucks
two pairs of shift the caps lock is huge
two caps locked hell yeah i want to
press that
caps lock so bad god damn isn't
windows itself really poorly designed
like we're all just supposed to know to
press control
on delete and alt f4 i remember when
they taught us that in school i was like
but
why am i is there not a better uh
just press those buttons both stalls
[Laughter]
nice nice i like that i like that a lot
these cinema cups hold they're with no
buttons so they only fit their super
large
drink cups oh my god have you guys ever
been to
cinema in uk because it's the worst i'm
always so uncomfortable
the seats suck you're crammed in i'm not
even i mean i am tall
but my legs are always hitting something
and it hurts i leave at the cinema
feeling like
at least give a somewhat better
experience you know i know in america
they try at least
russia made a world cup shaped water
bottle little did they know
it's a basically a giant magnifying
glass setting fire to everything
nice well done didn't they do that with
a shard in london
london skyscraper death threat
reflection is melting cars
burning businesses and all but also
cooking eggs
melting cars oh my god
melted cars oh it melted a car dude
let that sink in i heard that they
they're designing cities now to make it
so that
uh the structures doesn't reflect the
light in
so that in the cities it's actually
cooler than it is outside for really hot
cities and stuff like that
so cool that you can make things so much
better with just
smart people doing the job instead of
god
it doesn't have to be like this that's
the problem i think that's what annoys
you so much
but yeah that's crappy designs hope you
guys enjoyed this i had a lot of fun
watching it if you
watching it yeah we watched it together
uh leave a like
new merch if you are interested and see
you tomorrow breakfast
in a world where science knows no
boundaries
travel to land where no tuber has been
and explore never before seen landscapes
encounter beings that are extinct
meet mayan edgar's ancestors collect
ancient items rediscover
your favorite scientifically accurate
dinos
what will you create
you